well the latest we've heard is a
statement from the Department of Health
missus coming from Professor Chris
witties the chief medical officer he
says a further patient has tested
positive for corona virus which as we
know brings the total number of cases in
the UK to three quite telling the UK did
not the individual did not acquire this
in the UK the patient is being
transferred to a specialist NHS Centre
I'll tell you more about those in just a
second and we're using robust infection
control measures to prevent any possible
further spread of the virus and it goes
on to say the NHS is well prepared to
manage these cases and we're now working
quickly to identify any contacts the
patient has had that is the key that is
exactly what doctors clinicians and
anyone else involved in treating this
patient will be most concerned with
obviously the patient's health is the
priority but they will now be working
backwards to see just how much or who
has come into contact close contact this
is that this has to be close proximity
contact not just someone who's been on
the same bus or the same coach or the
same plane but somebody who has been in
close personal contact with a patient
they will be trying to make that
connection those links there and working
backwards to see who this patient has
been in contact with those treatment
centres there are five specialist
treatment centres that we know about
that can treat these coronavirus
patients they have specialist teams and
they are well equipped to deal with this
there is one in Newcastle two in London
one in Sheffield and one in Liverpool so
it's possible that this patient has been
taken to one of these centres for
treatment
you